now today for our daily cancellation
we'll be canceling all white members
of the critical race theory cult really
all members of all races
should be canceled if they're in the
cult but today we're focusing on the
white ones uh two pieces of evidence to
present
first rod drear uh has the screenshot
apparently from a northwestern
university law school
uh a town hall meeting they did online
and as dre describes it
the meeting started with a ritualistic
denunciation of racism from all the
participants
and so really it sounds like an a.a
meeting except with white guilt instead
of alcoholism here's a screenshot
so you've got emily who says my name is
emily i am a racist and a gatekeeper of
white supremacy
i will work to be better first of all a
gatekeeper of white supremacy sounds
almost like she's a gargoyle or
something that sits outside the palace
and asks you a riddle if you want to
enter
i am the white supremacy gatekeeper
answer these three riddles and you shall
pass that's what it sounds like to me
that's what i think every time maybe
it's just me
um anyway then sarah says thank you all
so much
my name is sarah and i'm a racist i will
try to be better
and james says i'm james and i am a
racist
now hang on a second why didn't he say
he'd be better is he not going to try to
be better
what are you saying james that's pretty
disturbing well actually never mind
according to critical race theory white
people can't not be racist
so trying to be better seems futile
another recent example of this kind of
thing a report from the daily wire
tells us that closing an 11 30 a.m
catholic mass
last sunday in new york city pastor
kenneth bowler
asked mass participants to join him in a
racial justice prayer that acknowledged
and denounced so-called
white privilege as the church's streamed
mass panned to images of george floyd
briana taylor
and ahmad arbory um the church of
saint francis xavier a roman catholic
parish in the jesuit traditi of course
damn jesuits of course it's jesuit
every every time i'm telling you jesuits
uh showcase the images of the alleged
victims of racial injustice at the front
of the church to this left side of the
altar
um okay so that there's the story but
let's actually play we have we have
video of the of the racial justice
prayer have your
vomit buckets ready as we check out this
prayer watch
i now invite you to stand and join
joining us in the prayer for
racial justice by responding yes to each
of the following statements
thanks do you support racial justice
equity and compassion in re
and human relations yes do you affirm
that white privilege is unfair and
harmful to those who have it and to
those who do not
yes do you affirm that white privilege
and the culture of white supremacy must
be dismantled where it is present
yes do you support racial equity justice
and liberation for every person
yes do you affirm the inherent worth and
dignity of every person
yes therefore from this day forward
will you strive to understand more
deeply the injustice and suffering white
privilege and white supremacy cause
yes will you commit to help transform
our
church culture to one that is actively
engaged
in seeking racial justice and equity for
all for everyone
yes will you make a greater effort to
treat all people with the same respect
you expect to receive
yes will you commit to developing the
courage to live
your beliefs and values of racial
justice and equality
yes will you strive to eliminate racial
prejudice from your thoughts and actions
so that you can better promote the
racial justice efforts of our church
yes will you renew and honor this pledge
daily knowing that our church and our
community
our nation and our world will be better
places
because of our efforts yes
let us pray all right first of all
that's not a prayer that's an
affirmation of belief
in fact it's it's uncomfortably similar
to the renewal of baptismal promises
that they also do during mass usually
when there's a baptism
if you're not catholic that's the part
at the end of the godfather when michael
corleone is answering yes to
do you renounce satan and all his and
all his works and the other questions
while his hitmen are executing all the
rival mob bosses
um this is also a renewal of baptismal
promises of sorts except it's renewing
the promises of your baptism into the
cult of critical race theory
and what you just saw there rises to the
level of really sacrilege with the photo
of a
violent criminal who forced his way into
a woman's house and robbed her at
gunpoint right up there on the altar
but even without that this is blm
marxist propaganda being spouted by a
priest
from the altar and you know i think it's
important for us to understand something
not all of this stuff is empty virtue
signaling a good portion of it is
certainly that priest for example i mean
that's that's nothing but empty virtue
signaling
i doubt that man is capable of really
firmly believing anything at this point
many of these baby boomer priests in
america are just hollow vessels of
platitudes and cliches that's all
they've ever been
they've been pastoring churches for
decades never in their lives have they
uttered a single meaningful word from
the pulpit
ever not even once the church is plagued
by these types so
for him yes i'm sure it is empty just
like everything else he says and does
but what about the people in in the chat
you know they're confessing their racism
perhaps it's just a gesture a virtue
signal it could be a cave to peer
pressure
or maybe not i mean this idea that all
white people are racist
and that we all must confess our racism
and actively work to dismantle it
even though again we can't because it's
inherent supposedly but
this is an idea that many people have
really bought into
now if you're an intellectually
susceptible person of a non-white race
it makes sense why you'd buy into it it
provides as we discussed yesterday
a convenient villain for your story
making a villain a scapegoat out of some
other
group some out group some other some
them well
that's a coping strategy as old as
civilization itself nothing new about
that
nothing confusing about it either but
no matter how intellectually susceptible
a white person is
why would they buy into this i mean why
would people
in the group being cast as villains
actually accept and embrace that role
what's going on with that well because
the priests and priestesses
critic of critical race theory knows
something that every other cult and
religion
knows which is that humans deep in their
souls
struggle fundamentally with two things
resentment and guilt
the resentment and guilt are oftentimes
a bit formless and shapeless
you aren't sure why they're there or
where to direct them and so humans go
looking for
outlets for answers for reasons why do i
feel this way
where do these feelings come from these
are questions that people especially
these days spend a lot of time asking
themselves we are very focused on our
own feelings in this culture
and depending on where you look you get
different answers psychologists will say
well those feelings are disorders
here take this pill self-help gurus will
say those feelings are illusions here
are some affirmation mantras you can
repeat in the mirror every morning to
make them go away
cults will say that they come from
wherever the aliens living in volcanoes
i think that's scientology i may be
getting the theology a little bit wrong
religions have answers too christianity
says this is our fallen nature it could
be conquered through christ repent and
believe
and critical race theory the newest
religion in america comes along and says
well
if you're non-white you have resentment
because you're a victim of systemic
oppression
if you're white you have guilt because
you are racist
and at some level you know it and here
is how to assuage
your guilt all you have to do is confess
your racism pledge to be anti-racist
take a knee raise your fist do this do
that here's the choreography here are
the prayers the mantras here are the
beliefs and opinions you must adopt
this will make you feel better this will
rid you of the guilt
this will explain everything going on
inside you
see i think i think all people are are
looking for something that will explain
themselves to themselves that's what
philosophy is
uh what's what much of science is about
psychology politics all of it at some
level is an attempt by human beings to
figure out who they are
what they are and why they are the way
they are critical race theory steps in
to offer its own rather
horrid explanations and it's not a
coincidence that it takes hold in a
culture
where the other avenues of explanation
the better avenues like religion
are waning it's also not a coincidence
that religion especially christianity in
the west
started waning when it stopped talking
about and acknowledging the darker
aspects of human nature
pastors like the one you just saw there
started saying well i don't want to talk
about guilt because
people will be uncomfortable and they'll
leave what they didn't realize is that
that's exactly what people want to hear
about they struggle with these parts of
themselves they come to religion for
answers
if you refuse to give those answers
they'll go elsewhere for them
enter critical race theory the new cult
the new religion
and one that is infecting the minds of
many americans especially younger
americans and destroying our country
in the process but today
i have put a stop to that with my
cancellation
because that's all it takes i wave my
magical cancel wand
and now sanity has returned you're
welcome
thank you for tuning in to the daily
wire one of the fastest growing
conservative
outlets in the entire country if you
enjoyed this video be sure to give it a
like and then subscribe to our youtube
channel so you don't miss out on any of
our content